they were cousins across the Atlantic
the Ford console in Europe and the
Mercury Cougar in America
in 1972 ford europe introduced the
console in germany and three body styles
2 and 4-door sedans and the tres chic
sports sedan the consoles 2 litre v6
engine put out around 90 horsepower
buyers could also opt for a lesser 2
liter 4 v sx engine the consul's design
was a product of 1970s tastes
the 1974 cougar was built to American
dimensions at five and a half meters
long and two meters wide it was too big
for Germany's average garage mercury was
a mark of the Ford Motor Company till
2011 the first generation 1967 cougar
was based on the sporty Ford Mustang but
by the mid 1970s it had been transformed
into something of a battleship a gas
guzzler that could have hardly been more
ill-timed at the start of the oil crisis
seen through today's ice the massive
sedan looks way too bulky but that was
1970s American car design nothing
elegant or sleek about it just heft
the buyer could order it with the seven
and a half litre 380 horsepower
big-block engine
the spacious interior and richly padded
seats gave the driver the feeling of
sitting and the luxury office is some
Texas oil tycoon
Derk Solomon rents out village cars in
Berlin including a cougar and a console
they can lend a wedding party a touch of
nostalgic extravagance
the Kouga explains that people who rent
the Cougar mainly went to drive an
engine that has four more cylinders than
their own car and feel the power in the
1970s the Cougar was one of the last
American cars with a truly big engine
but the Ford console attracts mainly
younger people who think it's cool to go
for a spin in a color from the 1970s
Dirk says if he felt like stepping on
the gas and really letting it rip he
definitely choose the Cougar yet there
are also times when he thinks it would
be nice to drive the Ford console it was
a common sight here in Germany in
contrast you could have counted the
Cougars in Germany on one hand and so
his favorite for here and now is the
Cougar the seventies mustache Prada
glasses and gold chains go with the
Cougar like fries with a hamburger
unfortunately so does its fuel
consumption a whopping 20 litres per 100
kilometers
in the early 70s the console and its
successor the Granada were Germany's
taste of the American Way of drive as
the pseudo English slogan went even
though Ford scaled the American inspired
model to European dimensions it was
still too big for many German buyers
the Ford plant in Cologne followed
American design cues black plastic up
down and all around
both cougar and console were upholstered
in vinyl
at first glance the console seems a
relic of the world of glam-rock
sideburns and platform shoes but this is
exactly the cars allure for today's
classic fans and the German Ford's
handling feels surprisingly modern even
sporty especially compared to its
American cousin
bigger is not always better or more
expensive a vintage console in good
condition can be had starting at 6,000
euros if you can find one but a
second-generation Mercury Cougar would
easily cost twice as much the two Ford
sedans are from two different worlds but
they have in common
70s nostalgia